[Música]
una semana más bienvenidos a cultura de
france 24 en el programa anterior
señalamos al talibán como una amenaza a
los derechos de mujeres y niñas como un
riesgo histórico para el arte y todos
sus creadores la diferencia entre
entonces y hoy es que afganistán ya es
un emirato islámico sin presencia
estadounidense ni aeropuerto operativos
ergo sin menoscabar al pueblo afgano
quienes hayan promovido la cultura corre
en peligro en palabras del fundador del
instituto nacional de música al diario
ara como en los 90 bajo su poder que
recuerda el doctor sar más la música
pronto podría ser prohibida con castigos
por oírla con instrumentos destruidos
como ya ocurrió con una pintura mural
del poeta alí si es nabai considerado
padre de la literatura uzbeka y así con
todo el patrimonio o expresión que
resume occidentalismo por ello con el
siguiente informe seguimos retratando a
los artistas afganos desde los que
rápido se marcharon por ser más
conocidos hasta los que permanecen con
miedo ocultos
suspenso tensión y un sentimiento de
urgencia esta frenética salida de
afganistán podría encajar en cualquier
película de acción pero para sacar a
karim y todo fue demasiado real esta
directora afgano iraní la única con
doctorado en cine y pionera en dirigir
la agencia estatal afgana film fue una
de tantos que se apresuraron a escapar
de su país ante la toma de poder talibán
sensaciones que también vivió la
realizadora a su hermano saadat que se
encontró en una huida desesperada y a
contrarreloj en el caos del aeropuerto
de kabul con visa otorgada por eeuu y
sin acceso a su dinero en el banco logró
alcanzar tropas francesas junto a su
familia ya desde francia país que la
premio en cannes en 2016 siente una
mezcla de emociones y síndicos es muy
triste porque nueve de mi familia
pudieron salir porque sé hablar inglés
soy cineasta y el mundo me conoce estoy
muy orgullosa pero al mismo tiempo estoy
muy avergonzada porque digo porque yo
soy mejor que otros yo estoy a salvo
pero hay muchas muchas muchas personas
allí y no sabemos si podrán lograrlo
hay gente con makers la fotógrafa rada
akbar fue otra artista que pudo escapar
a tiempo y refugiarse en parís en su
arte refleja la pérdida el dolor y la
opresión de la sociedad afgana su
exposición a barça nan se enfoca en
figuras femeninas y víctimas de
asesinatos colectivos su práctica fue un
acto de oposición desafiante y
triunfante hasta hace muy poco
me siento profundamente triste de estar
aquí hoy es devastador darles de estas
palabras a ustedes escritores activistas
defensores de los derechos humanos
madres padres niños
triste porque no todos han logrado salir
de kabul este coreógrafo y bailarín de
hip hop de 27 años siente que el mundo
ha cortado los vínculos con afganistán y
que su vida corre peligro solo por el
arte que desarrolla durante el primer
régimen talibán el baile suponía la
muerte física incluso la música la odian
- les gusta el breakdance dicen que es
la cultura occidental el hip hop es la
cultura occidental que se originó en
nueva york' es la cultura estadounidense
lo odian absolutamente además de temer
por su numerosa familia muchos
funcionarios del antiguo gobierno
también teme que algún vecino lo delate
antes de poder encontrarse con su
hermano en españa'
[Aplausos]
las personas que viven en mi vecindario
gente que conozco podrían llevar mi
nombre a los talibanes y decirles ese
tipo estuvo haciendo esto antes de que
vinieran así que obviamente una persona
como yo no será permitida pero tampoco
se me permitirá vivir por las cosas que
hice antes
una sensación de amenaza que acecha a
múltiples artistas frente a ella algunas
voces internacionales se han alzado como
la de tom morello de rage against the
machine que ha solicitado ayuda para
rescatar a un grupo de jóvenes y niñas
estudiantes de guitarra el colectivo
conocido como grow with the guitar
ha colaborado con músicos
estadounidenses y usa este instrumento
para sanar traumas razón suficiente para
hoy estar en riesgo extremo
[Música]
ojala afganistán fuera la fiesta que
protagoniza ahora la mostra de venecia
suena evidente que sean cara y cruz
noche y día pero también se debe al
trabajo del festival que ha convertido
su edición 78 en un abrazo a ese cine
que pone en valor al cine qué significa
esto que su selección dentro y fuera de
competencia devuelve la ilusión de
llenar las salas con películas acabas
cuál es mejor y con más de la mitad
superando las 2 horas de duración y
tiene mérito porque el evento tiene filo
más antiguo ya se arriesgó el año pasado
a la presencialidad y en pandemia vuelve
a doblar la apuesta pese a las pcr si
las proyecciones al 50 por ciento
próximamente del clan haremos estos
títulos pero desde ya les abrimos boca
citando almodóvar a paolo sorrentino y
en campeón pablo larraín ridley scott
post greider vaya buen apetito
y las patatas alguna vez estás
ofreciendo de trabajar
[Música]
el pase sanitario exigido en la muestra
empieza a ser común en la cultura el
certificado ya es ley en italia en
francia en urbes como nueva york' pero
está lejos de ser la panacea que
requiere el sector en concreto a los
museos tras año y medio de pandemia hoy
sabemos que entre un 6 y un 30 por
ciento cerrarán por falta de visitantes
extranjeros que se oponen un 70 a 90 por
ciento del público de una gran
institución este dato del consejo
internacional de los museos afectará
sobre todo a eeuu mientras que asia y
áfrica sufrirá más la pérdida de una
tercera parte de sus ingresos
broadway ha perdido millones y millones
de dólares sin embargo este septiembre
pone fin al cierre más largo de su
historia gracias a productores e
inversores privados de ahí este corto de
celebración con el que la asociación de
teatros recuerdan la emoción de las
tablas eso sí ante un aforo 100%
vacunado
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y aunque chile y por extensión
latinoamerica tiene otros tiempos ante
el virus está en lo cierto en seguir
investigando cómo se comporta en citas
culturales para ello realizó su primer
concierto en 17 meses en un ensayo de
200 asistentes con test y mascarillas el
rol de chancho en piedra fue volver a la
vida
en términos de ventilación en términos
de uso de mascarilla alcohol es que el
de niveles de co2 información científica
para que existan protocolos que le den
mayor estabilidad al sector y mayores
aforos para que la música chilena vuelva
con fuerza a los escenarios en forma muy
continua fuerza y especialmente jarana
como gritan los personajes tokio y río
es la quinta temporada de la casa de
papel un alboroto que regresa con dos
avisos el primero del creador a la
espina es que hasta diciembre no
conoceremos el destino de los
atracadores ya que su final está pensado
en dos partes de cinco capítulos el
segundo lo ponemos nosotros y es dejarse
llevar por su frenesí de despedida y su
total españolidad con la aceptación de
este juego es que ciertos altibajos y
tramas estiradas pasan para solo gozar
del genio de una serie que ha llenado el
mundo de máscaras de darín cuentan con
resistencia flash backs y grandes dosis
de violencia y villanía más que
reflexiones
en el mismísimo banco de españa nos ha
ayudado a todos a entender ya ganar
confianza en los proyectos que hacemos
no ya entender que también somos capaces
de hacer cosas
que antes a lo mejor sólo hacían los
americanos una serie y desde el
principio
fue ambiciosa en términos de género con
el que además netflix dice y lo manda y
lo manda el mundo entonces de pronto
david davis david david se convierte en
una fuerza que compite contra un goliat
antes siempre mirábamos como bueno esto
es algo a lo que no podemos acceder no
y sin esperanza
estamos contra las escuelas
pero todavía no estamos muertos
[Música]
en la última fuerza
ahora
saben que de cierre aportamos una nota
musical pero hoy nos despedimos con todo
un universo sonoro dulcemente
comprometido y resistente pues en un
único tema eso muestra a la cantautora
estará curruchiche de origen maya
kaqchikel guatemalteca se trata de
pueblos un homenaje indígena global y
latinoamericano que sigue la estela de
su tributo y tzotzil de 2020 pero que
esta vez cuenta con una maestra su
maestra la mexicana lila downs además
tiene un rasgo distintivo y es la
movilización y unión de estos pueblos
ante la pérdida del miedo a la
injusticia debido a otra piel otra
cultura y otra forma de hacerlo estos
últimos años hemos nos hemos dado cuenta
que muchos pueblos indígenas de toda la
américa abya yala
se ha movilizado han compartido muchas
de sus resistencias durante esta
temporada de pandemia también han
crecido mucho la
criminalización y el asesinato de
defensoras y defensores del territorio
de los pueblos indígenas entonces pensar
sentir una canción bien parada para la
lucha es
de nuestra parte de una forma de
acompañar y de actuar
[Música]
hola
de ella
en entrevista france24 q roo sí sí nos
escribió que el son de su país el son
jarocho las guitarras que apelan a
áfrica y las trompetas a méxico son
elementos al servicio de un viaje por
los distintos pueblos del planeta porque
puede que se llamen diferente o que
suenen diferente pero fusionados con la
marimba típica de sus canciones resuenan
las mismas problemáticas
pueblos tiene en la percusión hay una
forma de tocar el sol en guatemala que
muchas veces es un poco pausado
y la percusión tambor
bueno las parinas que también la
acompañan son de guatemala es muy
emocionada porque está esta producción
de este segundo disco también ha sido
una forma de tener un viaje a a mi
interior a mi ser como mujer indígena de
las temáticas de las canciones de este
segundo disco están muy marcadas con las
mujeres hacia las mujeres inspiradas
bien por está como te lo decía por la
tarde y forma toda la la luz y el sentir
aguerrido que han traído las mujeres a
lo largo del tiempo y con mucha fuerza
también rítmica con nueva generación
instrumentos que también es bastante
bailable con sara que nos acogió desde
méjico poniendo el acento en su habitual
reivindicación sobre el género nos
despedimos en junio recibió el premio
mtv transforma miedo por la lucha de esa
igualdad mientras que en octubre nos
brindará en un disco a un mayor poderío
y estaremos para contarlo hasta pronto y
cuídense mucho gracias
[Música]
/
escuchar
[Música]
suena fuerte y no
[Aplausos]